now a grocery store chain is expanding
with a new store in North Las Vegas it's
located on Losi near East Centennial
Parkway which is a really growing area
very close to the 215. eight news now
reporter Brian will stop by the grand
opening of sprouts to see how it will
fill a need for Neighbors
excited because another
[Music]
diabetic so I love to eat organic foods
this 12th Sprouts location has created
about 80 new jobs in North Las Vegas and
is offering more fresh fruits and
vegetables compared to other places on
this side of town it has brought people
like Jalen Singleton into this store I'm
also a vegetarian so I really wanted to
just try like try out the vegetarian
options and see what it was about
housing construction is booming in the
neighborhood which is near North Las
Vegas VA Medical Center and a soon-to-be
Helios Medical Campus this new Sprouse
location will give North Las Vegas
residents more options when it comes to
groceries here in this growing part of
the valley as for why the move to this
area the manager of this new store says
the brand does years of research before
deciding where to open up another
location makes sense to move into areas
where we have smaller stores in more
geographical locations so we can offer
better customer service that variety and
again that farmer's market type of field
the city of North Las Vegas stating the
timing is perfect and is a convenient
way for people to access healthy food as
for the competition this store says the
more places around the better some
competitors in the market but none of
them offer the unique shopping
experience that we do we're very proud
to be here in North Las Vegas I'm just
excited about the store being in the
area and having another option of where
to go shopping
another opening happening just a few
miles from that store on Monday the very
long-awaited arrival of Olive Garden
along Restaurant Row which is on Craig
between North 5th Street and the 15
freeway in fact construction continues
for a number of restaurants all along
that corridor